kto n nami's life Journey has been one
hell of a roller coaster ride from being
an average jiujitsu sorcerer who watched
his best friend pass away to that of a
depressed Celery Man Who had no meaning
in life to finally one of the strongest
Sorcerers and jutu kaisen and someone
who drove me to create this channel but
let's also not forget that nanami as a
complete pad ass like the first time he
showed up and went overtime in the anime
was as someone who hated working
overtime pure Bliss man like it was
actually amazing either way Kinto namami
is a grade one jutu sorcerer who after
10 or 11 years as a salary man quit his
everyday job and returned to the
jiujitsu academy to work with Gojo the
reason that he left the academy in the
first place is that n armi hated the
lessons that were being taught to him
when it came to accepting that they must
throw away their lives for others he
felt that everyone held a value in this
world and that their lives were precious
so naturally with Sorcerers being people
who put their lives on their line day in
and day out for the safety of a civilian
population who didn't even know what
they did had struck a cord with an Our
Man especially after seeing the death of
his closest friend Yu I'd say that was
probably the final straw that made him
step down after he finished his time at
jutu Tech so back in the past and as I
slightly mentioned before nanami had
once been a student at Tokyo jutu High
during his first year in 2006 he found
himself working with a uara together
they joined the second years sugu and
Gojo to help them on a mission in
Okinawa more specifically as protection
during the Eraser of Rico after
protecting the airport and I guess doing
some body guard work around the
outskirts of the town for these guys it
basically turned into like more of a
summer vacation for them than an actual
mission after a year had passed from
that date nanami again teams up with you
for one more difficult mission where
they were assigned to defeat a cursed
Spirit which was believed to be grade
two however after arriving and
discovering that the curs spirit wasn't
a pathetic one and had actually become
more powerful of the emotions of nearby
people it was revealed as a grade one
curse spirit that was far too strong for
you or n armi to deal with sadly this
end in you haar's death n Nami took
you's death differently from everyone
else as the Jew had formed a close Bond
over their time together as First Years
I'd say that nami's views on being a
jiujitsu sorcerer were probably warped
in that exact moment and like I'd
previously mentioned it fully drove him
to disown the jiutu society it's kind of
just sad when you think about it and
everything because youu was probably
like this light in an Army's life that
he loved to be around and everything and
having that light utterly stuffed out
and killed made him not want to be there
any longer even with Gojo being around
he didn't see a point to even stay there
anyway namami still did graduate from
jiu high but instantly decided to stop
being a sorcerer because he found it a
pain in the B and had already had way
too many traumatic experiences through
it so that there pretty much brings us
to today back in 2016 or 17 I doubt it
2018 because namami did initially come
back when UDA was around something that
I absolutely love and actually didn't
realize until recently was what n nami's
name means so Kento means cure for
depression and anami means building man
first it it makes sense because the
Kento part of his name cured the
darkness or the depression of the baker
lady behind the counter by defeating the
cursed Spirit hovering around her and he
takes out depressing curses on a daily
basis on his second thought though it it
actually totally doesn't as namami looks
more depressed than anyone else in the
series building man is another
interesting one I think it probably
portrays nanami's work life we all know
he works like an absolute dog building
up his life until he figured out that
being a salary man or sorcerer still
made life feel like no matter what
a major turning point for idor comes
when Kento armi is introduced to him by
Gojo while on a mission to investigate
The Uncanny deaths of three students at
a theater Gojo entrusted an armi with
ador's training on this Mission but the
two of them had different core values
which made it hard for them to initially
get along after hearing his reasoning
for joining jusu Society namami doesn't
approve of teaching yui but can see that
that he wants to get stronger so we
decided to accompany him either way
moving on to the theater case or the
theater Arc n armi teaches idor to see
the remnants of cursed energy and
following those said remnants Theo comes
across cursed Spirits throughout the
battle namami teaches Yuji his
techniques and showcases his skills and
fighting cursed Spirits just when Yuji
got his cursed energy all fired up and
was about to finish off the curse Spirit
n armi stopped him and instead took a
photo of the curse confused over like
what he was doing as typically curses W
show up in photos the Army revealed to
Yuji that sadly he wasn't actually
fighting curses but instead transfigured
humans taking on this information
shatters yuji's morals and causes him to
not feel good about the quickly evolving
situation Ben an armi along with shoko
on the phone explains that it is okay to
kill the transfigured humans this is
just like pretty much because they're
already brain dead at that point of
transfiguration shoko also explains to
Yuji that he wasn't the one to kill the
transfigured humans because they had
initially died of shock when their
bodies were being modified Yuji still
can't get over it and reveals that the
death of two transf good humans he
killed earlier still weighs on him
heavily seeing Yuji get angry on the
behalf of modified humans and army
realizes that Yuji can truly feel
empathy for others and take their
emotions on board so to snap him out of
the downward spiral he was currently in
and get Yuji to use those emotions in
combination with his own curse energy
Nami explained that it was time to go
all out and fight the other Spirits over
in the high school office now namami
shows Yuji a map on what you pen the
locations where our natural deaths took
place and an attempt to triangulate them
and find out the culprit Hideout Nami
also assigns Yuji to investigate junip
to find out more about the theater case
since he was present there adori gets
busy with his own investigation
regarding junip and so does namami with
these transfigured humans while Yuji is
off doing his thing with junip namami
goes to the sewers and forces mahito to
leave the Dank environment he calluses
place of residence the Army in mjo's
rivalry begins in the sewers when the
big man himself being punctual promises
to defeat mjo quickly as he doesn't like
to work over time hearing this mjo mocks
namami by calling him weake and from
that moment the battle begins namami
slashes at mjo with his cursed tool and
manages to break his arm off but it's in
vain since mjo through his Idol
Transfiguration technique heals his arm
and wounds NATO also shows the Nami his
collection of human stock piles while
explaining how he makes cont with the
human soul and Alters their body shape
obviously like namami doesn't want to
waste any time and has to get off work
at 600 p.m. no matter what so he decides
to end the battle as quickly as possible
mjo tries his best to tie anami out but
you know it's over when namami loens his
tie and Knots it around his hand in
preparation to go over time yolked up
namami explains his 73 ratio technique
which creates a weak point at a specific
location and automatically tracks his
strike to it he also reveals that he can
create this line along more than just
their full height or wing span and
designate it along various body parts
for instance the head upper arm forearm
and so on also on top of that nami's
curse technique can actually affect more
than just living creatures as the battle
continues it was pretty evident that
there were two ways in which namami
could defeat mjo one way was to exercise
mjo while the other was to reduce him to
smother rings in a single Blow instead
though n armi created his 73 ratio line
on his opponent's surroundings
destroying them while also being able to
cut mjo's leg off in the process with
mjo unable to move n armi BS fwell to
his opponent as a mountain of Boulders
quickly pounded the patch face curse
into the floor and just like that my man
pushed a currently semi- grade one curse
Spirit to the brink of death kind of I I
only say seei right now cuz man's still
growing but as we all know mjo escapes
here after mjo escaped of course like he
did the most despicable thing he could
think of and manipulated junip which
leads us to the next moment n appears so
remember the high school Ando along with
sakuna laughing their asses off over
yuji's mental breakdown well just after
that and as Maho was about to deal the
Kelling blow naami arrived just in time
to save yug seeing what's currently
going on the grade one sorcer decides to
scold the student for ignoring his order
lasater on and asks for a status update
Yuji reveals that sadly he was unable to
save junip or his mother from the curses
namami notices how Yuji is always
thinking of others before himself and
decides to ask about yuji's individual
status always resilient and despite
being stabbed several times by m already
Yuji insists that he's fine noticing the
salary man Mido expresses his joy and
reunites him with namami looking at the
curse namami sees that his nose is
bleeding and comes to the conclusion
that Yugi is able to harm majito he also
quickly realizes that if this is the
case there must also be a reason as to
why mjo can't currently kill Yuji in
order to take advantage of this now me
develops a strategy to use his curse
technique to stifle mjo's movement while
relentlessly attacking with Yuji who can
eventually land a killing blow the Juro
prepares for the fight and N armi
declares that they must exercise mahito
here and now getting ready mahito
prepares himself by creating an eyeball
on his left palm while morphing his
other into a bladed shape he plans on
using the eye to watch Yuji while
focusing on killing an armi first mjo
engages both Sorcerers with Yuji on the
left and anami on his right anami
rapidly deflects mjo's ated arm while
Yuji goes for a low kick thanks to the
eye on mjo's hand he's able to jump
above yuji's kick while sword fighting
with namami at the same time while in
the air hoo transforms his entire body
into a sphere of extending spikes the
sorcerers are just able to evade and
Parry this to break the spikes apart
making mjo regret using this type of
attack after breaking all of these
spikes apart yui and an armi prepar to
deal a massive combined blow however Meo
was able to evade by transforming his
body into a childlike version of himself
and slipping between his opponents
having watched this both namami and Yuji
are able to notice that mjo stores up
his curs energy just before transforming
knowing that one hit from Yuji could
actually kill him in his smaller form
Meo changes back to normal and spews out
several transfigured humans then using
Idol Transfiguration he creates several
mutated corpses that are ordered to kill
Yuji knowing how mentally incapable Yuji
currently is when it comes to taking a
life namami tries to intercept the
transfigured children but mjo who seizes
the opening nearly takes his head off
with his bladed arm seen it coming
namami uses his Superior reflexes and
Ducks Under the Blade at the last second
with no we to go now Meo transforms his
arm into a much larger mutation and pens
the Army to the wall of a nearby
building while claiming that Yuji won't
be able to kill the mutated humans at
the same time yui escapes to the roof
and tries to pin down one of the
transfigured humans to avoid fighting
heing the groggy voice of the curse
trying and ask for their lives to be
ended the words horrify Yugi who's left
unable to do anything over in the other
fight hio plans on having Yuji
eventually fight a transfigured naami
and boasts that the student is a fool
for not being able to distinguish
expectations from reality namami who
knows that Yuji will eventually be able
to Grapple with the idea of fighting
transfig humans calmly replies that
mahito is the fool and Yuji is making
that distinction at this very moment
right on Q Yuji our boy jumps down from
the top of the roof and smashes down on
mjo's enlarged arm freeing an armi
knowing what was done he was satisfied
to know that he managed to kill the
transfigured humans but Yuji who can't
bring himself to yet understand the
reasoning for all this Bloodshed is
furious suddenly bignami appears next to
mjo ready to strike with his blunt sword
and a fraction of a second the curse
Spirit instantly reacts confident he can
counter an Army's curse technique
however yui cracks him hard with a
strong right hook allowing an armi to
follow up by creating a weak point in
mjo's face and smashing it with his
blunt sword the the teacher and student
then absolutely lay the fug out of mjo
until all of a sudden the curse can feel
death approaching using that impending
doomed to inspire the powers within the
depths of his own soul heo conjures for
the very first time his own domain
expansion the self- embodiment of
perfection with no Escape left for the
intended target it immediately locks
Yuji out and traps the armi alone inside
a void filled with maho's soul
transfiguring hands being a grade one
sorcerer nanami is strong enough to
fight against and even beat special
grade cursors because of that and duud
of the knowledge he possesses on how a
domain works the Nami immediately
realizes how bad of a situation this
currently is happy with himself as per
usual NATO expresses his gratitude for
the sorcerer helping him attain this
greater level of strength frustrated
that namami was the only one locked
inside yui rapidly bangs on the outside
of the domain expansion with his curs
energy infused firsts inside and
understanding the crap he's in naami
knows that his literally in the palm of
mjo's hands now after looking back on
the recent choices he made in regards to
quitting a celer man life and rejoining
jutu high namami accepts his fate and
tells mahito to save his gratitude since
he has plenty already taking off his
Shades n Nami proudly admits that he has
no regrets suddenly and before meso can
activate the Shad effect of a domain
expansion Yuji breaks into the domain by
shattering it from the outside this feet
by the way isn't actually that crazy the
domain's purpose is entrapment so
breaking it from the outside is
something that works as in theory it
should be extremely weak there obviously
cuz our boy has the Demon King inside of
him this instantly forces mahito to
touch yuji's Soul once again angering
sakuna due to the previous meeting
between the two the king of curses
reminds meito that there wouldn't be a
second warning and slashes his body with
two devastatingly deep Cuts this in turn
severely damages mahito and destroys the
rest of his domain dropping him to his
knees defeated several things instantly
run through yuji's head leading to the
decision that he needs to act quickly
and finish off maheso faing naked M
admits that the domain expansion has
drained most of his curs energy and
decides to use what he has left to
expand his body seeing the enlarged
balloon of cursed energy usually
believes that mahito was weak and unable
to Counterattack so with nothing holding
him back he filled his fist with a pulse
of intent and Strikes M's enlarged body
with Divergent fist however instead of
stry curse the body pops like a balloon
and mjo's real weakened body escapes
back into the sewers seeing it shoot out
an army attempts to stop him by
destroying the entrance but mjo still
manages to Scurry away that there brings
everything inside of the mahito arc with
naami to an end I know I kind of like
added in yuji's point of view a lot
throughout that there but you know what
I I think we kind of needed to to make
that flow a little bit better then Nami
also does make a like brief entrance
during the Kyoto Goodwill event Arc but
it's only to update go Ojo about what
happened previously with him and Yuji at
sat zakura High School the next time we
get to see the big man himself is join
the shabuya incident Arc where while
with meami and Tuma the three are
informed of the current situation
currently going on in shabuya later when
these citizens get attacked by mutated
humans n Nami along with Eno and Mami
head over in order to protect them n
Nami strategizes and divides the group
up as he wants them to all reach ador's
location once they do eventually reach
yuji's location the mini mamaru that he
has explains what had happened to them
against meso and what's the best course
of action for the upcoming night should
be namami agrees with ki's plan and says
that he will first need to lift his
screens around shabuya he also says that
instead of staying with the younger
Sorcerers he will go and meet up with
kot taka whilst Mami Yuji and Tuma deal
with urtin I I know Tuma is a young
sorcerer he's already a professional
sorcerer who's left school and
everything I don't actually know what
his grade would be considered as as well
I can't remember if it is put in the
story at all either way an army for the
time being puts the professional
sorcerer Tuma in charge and lets them
know that if they bump into noobo and
kusakabe they should explain the
situation before leaving himself after
journeying through shabuya namami finds
one of his best friends Kota lying
wounded on the ground seeing his
injuries literally pushes namami to the
Limit as it reminds him of how he lost
you in the past getting furious for his
friend namami for the first time in the
series throws away any thought of
holding back and angrily head it out in
search of whoever did this now he's just
like actually seriously pissed off and
oh my Lord I love this part of the
series plus mea came through freaking
clutch in this part as someone whose
whole reason for even starting jju
kaisen and like YouTube was D armi the
adaption of this section of the manga by
mappa is unreal like I actually had to
rewind this next part 18,000 times just
to take him this new kind of feeling
I've I've never had before like I'd
never seen my dad walk up on someone on
the B screen scam before and lay him out
but on that day there he stood having
come across noara in her moment of need
which is also just like when he saved
Yuji in his time of need n armi with a
conviction that would make the Earth
shake appears at the end of the corridor
her of the freak on a serious note for a
second here like for a villain this dude
is actually fantastic and I absolutely
love his messed up demeanor I give him
so much all of the time same with
mayoya but for villains they are
actually amazing characters but
unluckily for him to day he was unable
to say anything as he was still figuring
out whether or not he was allowed to
attack non-black suits speaking up shiko
tells the newcomer to read the room and
claims to have a hostage so he shouldn't
attack to his bewilderment though aari
crawls up the escalator to escape from
the curse user while shigo laments about
who getting away n armi appears right
behind him nanami asks where and how
many enemies there are shik replies that
he he doesn't know and turns around
upward slashing a number his shoulder at
the same time he tries to follow up with
a front kick but it's as if he hits a
mountain of stone looking up at the
sorcerer shik is confused since namami
didn't bunch at all from his attack and
he isn't cut either annoyed namami asks
the curse user the same question again
rut begins to say that he doesn't know
but namami doesn't even let the dude
fully answer before activating his Rao
technique in an instant he creates a
weak point on shik's eating face
and backhand the child with a a second
thought the impact blows shigo tumbling
through the air destroying anything in
his way and launching him across the
room into a wall behind nobara not
really knowing much about naami nobara
is just utterly surprised by how
ridiculously strong and overpowered he
is in comparison to shikimo standing up
as blood pours from his mouth shikimo
believes that he'd be dead without his
curse technique feeling the difference
in their strength shikimo knows that he
needs to run but before he can even move
namami grabs him by his hair and and
delivers a ferocious body blow that
slams shik into the wall shattering a
small part of it from the impact
coughing up even more violently now
shigo communicates with his cursed tool
which levitates up into the air and
attempts to stab an army from behind
catching sight of it nobara sends one of
her nails into the hand of the curo
pinning it into the wall shiku tells her
to not interfere but namami grabs him by
the throat with his left hand and begins
raising his right while filling it full
of cursed energy asking the same
question once more an army reveals that
he came across several dead assistant
managers on the way here he asks the
cursed user if he was responsible not
replying and fearful for his life chigo
tears up and apologizes but it's far too
late for that having lifting him up by
the throat and N armi drops his dumb ass
and hits him with one final blow
enhanced by the ratio technique and oh
my Lord my boy flips and Spins like no
tomorrow an armi legit Beyblades to it
rip on his ass and send him through
freaking everything the dude rocketed
through a wall outside into another wall
of a building across the street as the
dust then settled shiko was left
unconscious sitting in the crater caused
by the impact with blood profusely
pouring from his face this here I think
for like the first time in the series
makes no realize that namami is
completely on a different level and this
is what it means to be a true grade one
sorcerer I feel like before this moment
he was never really there to witness any
of those crazy fats like Gojo destroying
him army with purple Beck and the
Goodwill Arc or nothing to do with like
the first mjo stuff with Yuji but here
she was to witness what a true grade one
sorcerer is made of and well she'll need
to achieve that in the future if she
wants to stay around you know either way
moving forward after this the Nami
explains Gojo's situation to her and
AATA and says that he'll be shooting off
to try and save him now nabara wants to
help as well but namami explains that
this fight is for grade one Sorcerers so
she should back down it's kind of sad
when you think about how noara was meant
to be getting put up for that grade one
role as a sorcerer though it's kind of
like made her realize that she's not
ready for that role whereas Yugi is kind
of ready for that role that he's the
dude actually there with mjo and namami
being able to keep up I was truly happy
that namami actually got this moment
when I first read the Manga especially
before the next Stu that does eventually
happen without it I'd feel like a lot of
people might have started to think that
he was an overhyped teacher that the
grade one Sorcerers weren't all that
impressive and that the scaling method
introduc kaisen for like strength was
useless which you know it kind of is at
some points when it gets the special
gred above I think but with this though
it shows just how large of a gap there
is between each grade of sorcery in the
early on stages from nobara at grade
three to getting dominated bigo who's
meant to be grade two I think and
finally the G himself rolling in is a
grade one to save the day it gives the
power system Credence and shows that
sometimes it doesn't matter what the
technique is they just may be an
overwhelmingly stronger force that you
won't be able to stop no matter who who
you are either way enough of me rambling
on about like absolute nonsense after
leaving the girls namami neoo and Mari
come across Deon one of the special
grade cursed Spirits so kind of like the
previous stuff I'm just going to try and
stick with nanami's point of view
throughout this fight obviously I will
have to include some moments from other
characters and whatnot just to make it
flow but you know it's just n Army story
here so I'll try and keep it to like
what just happens with namami as the
fight starts namami watches neoo
attacking Deon and struggling a little
bit so he steps into to attack with his
own ratio technique he strikes down with
his blunt sword on gon which the curse
comfortably boxs with his forearm a
second later though and having found the
weak point n nami's curse technique
takes effect sending the gon crashing
back to the ground watching the other
two Sorcerers fighting the Army Dives
down on top of the curse and Strikes him
through the frame nearo would just stuck
him inside instead of getting hit like
last time though the gon blocks an
Army's sword with a shield of water
repelling the critical hits and
frustrating an arm army with a cursed
Spirit walking forth now a cylinder
shcked Water Shield Flows In A Circle in
the air around Theon to protect him
watch you note the Army feels like they
haven't done any damage due to this
cursor's boundless Health the sorcerers
ready their fighting stances as Nao asks
what their best course of action is then
they all strike in unison as the Old Man
reveals that the best way to counter is
to Simply overwhelm their adversary
before he can activate any techniques
the three jiutu Sorcerers all rapidly
attack G's Water Shield at the same time
threatening to crush him with pure speed
as they progress the sorcerer start
slowly piercing the water shield now
Beto's first manages to get through
first surprising to gone he decides to
wave a hand sign detonating the shield
into a massive explosion of water that
forces an army and Marky back and nowo
started about toon attempts to use
another hand signal but nowo tells him
to not even think about it instantly he
pummels the gon's midsection as well as
his hands with a flurry of downward
punches destroying his fingers and
making it possible for him to cast hand
signs however it turns out to be a
symbol distraction as a symbol appears
on gon's stomach signaling the
activation of his domain expansion this
traps Nito and theon's Coastal domain
Horizon of the captivating scander of
course n armi is also trapped inside
along with Mari who are both instantly
assaulted by piran like shikami the
crazy thing about these fish is that
they don't even exist until they hit the
target due to the effect of the domain's
sh hit effect not giving an actual stuff
about Mary at all which is just crazy
seeing what she's become later on the
gon decides to focus 70% of his own
power on neeso and the remaining 30% on
an army he activates technique release
death swarm summoning a literal death
swarm of fish shami to his side
anticipating the attack an army warns
Mary to attack without hesitation
because if she doesn't the shami will
instantly eat them alive sadly for our
girl his advice is interrupted when the
sugar gami attack n armi first and
appear to devour his upper body skipping
slightly forth and after the goat meami
makes his appearance by using his domain
expansion to enter from the outside Deon
calls meam a fo for entering voluntarily
and motions to attack him having gained
the playful Cloud the special grade
weapon with like no specific technique
from megami's endless well Maki stops
him by attacking from behind the strike
lands on the spirit cutting away a good
chunk of deon's armor and surprising him
with the force of the impact Maki whls
around the playful cloud and uses the
momentum of her spin for a powerful
followup attack strong enough to send
the special gr skitting across his own
water as the gon recovers from the heavy
blows he realizes that his guaranteed
head has been nullified because of
mami's domain to restore death swarm
Deon ignores Mari and focuses on
crushing meami due to how meami is
currently stuck in a domain struggle
toon believes killing meami will be
simple and spawns two eel like chami
from his body to attack in that moment
the actual rock of a human makes his
reappearance having survived death swarm
for an entire minute and protects Mami
standing next to the first year now he
asks where Yugi and Eno are and Mami
explains what it happened to each of
them grappling with what to do next n
armi tells meami to focus on his own
domain while the others protect him Deon
who actually baffled with how n armi
managed to survive death swarm for an
entire minute is taken off guard when
neoo throws a fierce left HW with his
one remaining arm but the gon manages to
duck underneath it he's shocked that
nowo as well managed to survive death
swarm's Onslaught for an entire minute
trying to overwhelm him now Mari comes
up from behind the gon and Rees her
weapon while simultaneously Deon blocks
a flying knee from the old man before
playful Cloud hurts Deon summons two
large Shar gami from his body to repel
the sorcerers the suar gami initially
pushes noobo across the sand but the
grade one sorcerer traps it inside a
frame and crushes it with a powerful
stomp behind na OBO mosa kagami head
towards Mami but naami stops them with
his ratio technique slashing them apart
with ease he believes that they might
win if they can keep up this momentum
but as blood begins to drip from
megami's nose it's evident that he's
reaching his limit surprising n armi
meami reveals that he's not actually in
the midst of a domain battle right now
he's trying to open a hole in the
barrier so they can escape rather than
enforcing his own expansion in his eyes
Deon likely can't use themain expansion
so if the sorcerers can escape they
might be able to win due to how he
entered meami is sure that the barriers
Edge is right below him hearing all of
this the Nami tells him that he he did
not be planning on staying behind
himself to which meami affirms that he
doesn't plan on throwing his life away
not not just yet anyway if you want to
know what I mean watch this video here
either way either way n Nami calls out
to his allies asking Mary and naito to
assemble on them he does so in a
roundabout way so that the curse doesn't
realize but the Zen and team trusts an
army and heads towards meami confused
about what they're doing Deon wonders
why they would get in a group and make
it easier for him to attack them it
takes a moment but he quickly realizes
Mam's plan and panics rushing to follow
them a step too late Nami sees that
theon's figured it out but he believes
that it's too late for him to stop them
now on Q meami opens a hole and everyone
Ries thems to leave the domain but
suddenly an unsuspecting Intruder enters
through it the recently resurrected toi
figuro uses the opportunity to climb
through the hole in the domain forcing
everyone there to Bear a witness to the
flesh of the one who was free and all
his overwhelming
intensity so I am actually going to skip
over everything that happens with toi in
this like next kind of chapter or two
space or maybe like episode that it
happens over it's probably going to be
like a quarter of an episode knowing how
quickly it actually happens but I'm
pretty sure namami doesn't really have
anything to do with what's about to
happen I'm like 90% sure he might only
ask whose side toi's currently on either
way and after murking the fish toi the
puppet of Carnage drags Mami off to deal
with his son for the first time in his
life instantly after Joo who's showing
up on the Block launches a surprise
attack on the already injured three
remaining Sorcerers and that moment Jer
also says his final farewell to Theon
and just like that blitzes namami igniz
in the upper half of his body this sadly
is where the beginning of the end the
namami story started after this Joo and
sakuna went head to head and as Yuji was
finally given control back over his body
after the fight he had an emotional
breakdown once seeing the destruction he
had caused probably somewhere nearby I'm
assuming that it's below where Yuji is
up on the surface and now he wakes up in
a pure days his upper body is completely
decimated with the left half of it being
burned to a crisp by joo's previous
attack even the entire left side of his
face is burnt flesh and Bone he keeps on
walking pushing forth when suddenly a
swarm of transfigured humans meet him as
he rushes forth in his last stand
slicing and hacking into every
transfigured human that comes towards
him he Daydreams about Malaysia and the
ideal life he wants to live there he
starts to look for mamy and Mary and
says that he's just tired while still
fighting like it's sick in nature to him
that there was until the worst thing
that could possibly happen came into
fruition meso appeared in front of him
with his hand placed on his chest the
Cur Spirit instantly tries to spark up a
conversation with him but n armi is
already his what's limit he hallucinates
and talks to his late partner youu hiara
he contemplates why he came back to
being a sorcerer and as he finishes his
question youu points at something to his
right in that very moment namami looked
over and saw yui running into this room
ah this yeah this always gets me always
cuts deep but as you could imagine this
was the perfect situation for meito
still fading between life and death
namami says to his best friend you that
he doesn't want to end up cursing yui
for his own fate with that as his final
thoughts the Nami Smiles in s at Yuji
the student who meant so much to him and
says his final words you've got it from
here as he finishes that statement Mido
uses his curse technique and destroys
the entire upper body giving Yuji one of
the most traumatic scenes he would ever
see after nanami's death adori gets
enraged and is determined to take
revenge for his Fallen Mentor May on the
other hand sends a small transfigured
human at idor and transforms it into one
that can produce spikes from its head
preoccupied by the feeling of rage and
revenge idor gets ready to fight sadly
it's actually so messed up but meso not
only killed yuji's Mentor but also his
new close friend that he was like
getting to know Jun so keeping these
people close to his heart and mind Yuji
becomes determined to finish off mahito
indeed konami's death did leave a
massive impact on everyone especially
idor since the armi tied right in front
of his eyes at first he probably didn't
even believe what had happened I
especially couldn't believe what had
happened I it took me like a few turn
backs of the page to realize what was
going on in the end it resulted in some
hardcore character development for our
boy since he felt emotions like rage and
hatred towards a specific being for the
first time in his life plus what happens
after here doesn't exactly help with
that feeling towards this man Yi lost
someone he really looked up to someone
who might have actually replaced that
Gap left by his grandpa so having lost
him left a scar on his heart from not
wanting to kill maded humans to wanting
to destroy all of his enemies idor has
changed a lot from this moment
throughout the story and en nami's death
was a catalyst of what was to come thank
you if you have made it to the end of
the video if you do want me to cover a
few more of like jiujitsu kaizen's
characters lives in full then make sure
to let me know down below and who you'd
like me to cover specifically you know
preferably I'd like to do the ones that
have passed on as that gives me a solid
beginning and end and I want to come
back and redo the characters at a later
date subscribe if you are also new
around here and want to watch a bunch of
similar anime and manga content plus
leave a like as it really helps out with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but for now it's been a
professional to generate de Volo and I
will see you all in a bit bye